having trouble keeping track of
spider-man's big screen adventures with
a cinematic legacy spanning nearly 20
years multiple directors and numerous
actors we don't blame you
so to help out we'll break down all the
events of Tom Hollands appearances as
your friendly neighborhood spider-man
step by step
surprisingly Peter Parker's first
appearance in the MCU doesn't come in
Captain America Civil War instead that
honor goes to Ironman to wear Tony Stark
saves a little kid during the climax of
the film while Tony's flying in to stop
Ivonne Blanco from using weaponized
hammer drones to attack the attendance
at the stark Expo a young boy in an Iron
Man mask raises his toy gauntlet to stop
one of the drones
Iron Man swoops in blasts the robots and
tells his pint-sized fan nice work
before blasting off again bands have
long speculated that the masked child
was actually a young Peter Parker years
before Marvel got the go-ahead from Sony
to officially add spider-man to the MCU
after all the stark Expo takes place in
Queens and Peter is a longtime science
geek who wouldn't miss the opportunity
to go to an event like that Tom Holland
told The Huffington Post in 2017 as far
as he and MCU head honcho Kevin Feige
are concerned the unnamed boy is
definitely Peter Parker the actor even
quote triple confirmed it so it's about
as canonical as one can possibly be
by the time spider-man homecoming hit
theaters audiences had seen Peter's
Uncle Ben die on the big screen twice in
two different franchises so it's no
wonder that the filmmakers of spider-man
homecoming chose to skip over that
particular part of spider-man's origin
story that said there have been enough
hints and references to make it clear
that the MCU version of Peter definitely
had an uncle band that he lost at some
point in spider-man far from home Peters
luggage looks secondhand and bares the
initials BFP the luggage almost
certainly belonged to one Benjamin
Franklin Parker before Peter used it
according to spider-man Home Coming
writers Jonathan Goldstein and John
Francis Daley and earlier draft of the
film would have seen Aunt May explicitly
mentioned her dearly departed husband
with all that we can pay Uncle Ben's dad
that around six months before the events
of Captain America's Civil War since
that film shows Peter telling Tony that
he's had his powers for six months Peter
even indirectly mentions that he blames
himself for Uncle Ben's so far
mysterious death by saying that when you
can do the things that I can but you
don't
and then the bad things happen they
happen because you in other words with
great power comes great response
six months after Peter gets his powers
Tony drops by Aunt May's apartment to
sample some of her walnut date loaf and
meet the mysterious arachnid themed
superhero who's been showing up on
YouTube Peter explains what he's all
about as a young superhero and Iron Man
adds him to his team of Avenger hunting
Avengers as part of his ongoing feud to
take down Bucky so Peter heads to Berlin
does some sightseeing and annoys Tony
Stark's bodyguard and Powell happy Hogan
then he gets a costume upgrade courtesy
of Tony Stark and fights against Captain
America Winter Soldier Falcon ant-man
Scarlet Witch and Hawkeye spider-man
acquits himself nicely in the fight
until the whole melee ends with Tony's
best friend Rhodey wounded by friendly
fire as for Peter he suffers a pretty
frightening fall although he ultimately
emerges unscathed
unlike Rhodey the whole experience seems
to put Tony off of the idea of using
literal teenagers to help him catch a
brainwashed former KGB assassin which is
probably for the best
however Peter seems to have had a good
time as he filmed pretty much the entire
battle after the harrowing events of
Captain America's Civil War Peter heads
back to Queens with his new more
technologically advanced spider suit
Tony tells Peter that the Avengers will
let him know if there are any future
missions and in the meantime he should
go to school and focus on being a local
hero two months later while swinging
around on his after-school
crime-fighting rounds he interrupts an
ATM heist organized by crooks who are
using high-tech and extremely dangerous
weapons
Peter eventually follows up on the
weapons dealers and gets into a fight
with their leader the vulture Tony sends
a drone to bail Peter out and give him
yet another talking to about how Peter
should stop trying to fight
supervillains can't you just be a
friendly
neighborhood spider-man but I'm ready
for more than that now no you're not
Peter have listens mostly to the parts
about how his suit has a ton of
capabilities that he didn't know about
and gets his buddy Ned to hack the suit
and give him full access round two with
the vulture in Washington DC ends with
Peter trapped in a warehouse for the
night and when he heads off for round
three on a ferry ride in New York it
turns out that Iron Man and the FBI had
organized the sting operation that Peter
inadvertently interrupts disappointed in
his protege Tony takes back the suit and
Peter recommit to his regular life and
asks his crush Liz to prom
unfortunately Bliss's dad is the vulture
forcing Peter to take him down in his
original low-tech suit before the wings
billing can steal a ton of valuable
stark tech spider-man succeeds vulture
goes to prison Liz moves to Oregon with
her mom and Tony offers Peter a place on
the Avengers roster if he wants instead
Peter turns him down choosing to focus
on being a friendly neighborhood
spider-man for a while last chance just
enough okay it's kind of a Springsteen
II working class here owned by a better
day when Thanos and his Black Order
invade Earth in search of the ultra
powerful Infinity stones and Avengers
infinity war spider-man hops right in to
help Iron Man Doctor Strange Bruce
Banner and Wong and defending Earth
Doctor Strange is kidnapped by the black
orders evany mall
and Peter chases after him hitching a
ride on mah spaceship before it flies
away completely
Tony quickly joins him giving the
younger hero the even more high-tech
super suit last seen at the end of foam
come in to help embattled Thanos his
crew of aliens Spidey and Iron Man freed
Doctor Strange blast ebony mall out into
space and land on Titan Thanos his home
planet they're quickly joined by some of
the guardians of the galaxy Peter quill
Drax mantis and nebula
the heroes prep to fight Thanos who soon
arrives to take dr. Strange's time stone
to add to his Infinity Gauntlet the
heroes put up a valiant effort but their
plan goes south and Thanos teleports to
earth after nabbing the time stone soon
after he gets the mine stone from vision
puts it all together and snaps his
fingers causing half of all life in the
universe to fade away
unfortunately Peters 50/50 probability
comes out on the negative side and he
turns to dust and Tony's arms on the
alien planet
afterthe anis kills off half of the
universe the remaining half is left to
mourn their fallen friends and family
unfortunately for Peter it doesn't seem
like there are many left to remember him
virtually all of his friends along with
Aunt May are blipped by Thanos after the
mad Titan snaps his big purple fingers
for the five years between door killing
Thanos in the beginning of Avengers
endgame and when Captain America gets
the gang back together it seems like the
only one left a mourn Peter is Tony
Stark he even keeps a framed picture of
his young Protege in the kitchen of his
cabin home luckily for spider-man Tony
eventually feels guilty enough to rejoin
the Avengers once he's back on the team
he develops a time machine goes back in
time to steal the Infinity stones before
Thanos could destroy them in the present
timeline and reconstructs another
Infinity Gauntlet and with one snap of
Hulk's mighty hand the dust that
happened the universe is restored
exactly how they were when they
disappeared
Thanos from a previous timeline heads to
the present in order to react to
oblivion but every superhero or
superhero adjacent character stands in
his way including spider-man what are
you doing oh this is nice
Peter joins the fight meets some of his
new superhero peers murders a bunch of
aliens with his suits instant kill mode
and then watches his Tony Stark gives
his life to dust Thanos his crew with
the snap of his own after all that space
alien craziness it's back to normality
for everyone's favorite wall crawler and
spider-man far from home well until he
finds himself suddenly embroiled in a
fight against multiverse elementals
alongside a superhero from another
universe Quentin Beck aka Mysterio to
make things worse Peter struggling to
live up to Iron Man's legacy and to
control a hi-tech sunglasses based AI
system called Edythe plus his feelings
for MJ are coming to a head puberty man
you look really pretty
and therefore I have value no no that's
not what I meant at all I was just I'm
messing with you
desperate for a mentor Peter gives up
the sunglasses to back whose magic
powers and Big Brother attitudes seem to
make him a better successor to Tony then
Peter could ever hope to be
unfortunately Becks running a con on
Peter as he's amassed a villainous group
of former Stark Industries employees to
help him tricked the world into
he's the next Ironman Peter learns the
truth then eventually defeats Mysterio
with the villain seemingly dying in the
final battle
Spidey returns to New York having saved
the day and everything seems to be going
well until that is Jay jonah Jameson of
the Daily Bugle dotnet leaks Mysterio's
dying confession and reveals to the
entire world that Peter Parker is
spider-man so we're all set up for a
nice neat follow-up to that cliffhanger
right well after Sony and Disney failed
to extend their spider-man agreement in
August 2000 19 the entire Spidey future
is up in the air the Sony continue were
far from home left off do they cash in
on the meme and go with a spider-man
homeless theme the possibilities are
endless and also unpredictable nobodies
spidey sense is tingling just yet check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stop or coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one